we have really big egos about our
business when I see a lot of the gym
owners that struggle it's just the big
obvious thing the sandwich sucks like
dude what's the new marketing thing for
like gyms I'm like have you tried your
sandwiches they are
terrible why would you want more people
to know like imagine I had a mediocre
book which is what most people would
have and then I spend tons of money
trying to Market it why would I do that
it sounds ridiculous when you think
about it you're like I'm just going to
let everyone know I'm mediocre that
would suck I think right now a lot of
you guys are just serving mediocre
sandwiches and I think if you spent a
year eating your own sandwich you would
immediately see all the things that are
wrong with it you'd fix that and then
the rest of your life you'd be able to
scale this thing